they said you were nothing but a toy
your lot in life was to entertain
children and then collect dust in the
basement but you said to hell with that
I was destined to battle the most
formidable military force ever assembled
I destined to pick up on um had so much
fun blowing bubbles and moonbeams at all
our new friends this is thus
we mean our stunning entrance riding
majestic unicorn their jaws are sure to
hit the floor our bullets were rained
down on the enemy we got cannons the
shoot fire into the heavens they will
tell stories of our bravery for years
who tell me wonder party tea parties
everyone will be so happy remembering
what an amazing day we all had together
because when you work as a team you can
destroy any army tales classroom there
will be more armies that you're moving
parts on its soldier your fight through
paint won't plastic limbs and rainbows
and sunshine and happiness and when you
emerged from battle down no you're more
than just a toy you are a toy soldier
you